hi my name is kendra sanchez and i play
dawn schaefer on season two of the
babysitter's club hi my name is malia
baker and i play marianne speer hi i'm
sophie grace i play christy thomas hi
i'm mona tamata and i play claudia kishi
hi i'm shay rudolph and i play stacy
mcgill hi i'm vivian watson and i play
mallory pike hi my name is annae lee and
i play jessie ramsey and we're the
babysitters club and we're playing who's
who with buzzfeed okay you have to send
me like telepathy
question one who's most like their
character everybody i cannot pick one
person because we are all so much like
our characters which is crazy but it's
just it's good casting i guess i'd also
have to choose everyone everyone is just
too similar to their characters to like
pick one individual out of all of us
yeah so i agree with you everyone this
is a tough one because i feel like we're
all electric
in some way i feel like shay and stacy
are like almost parallels you know it
tastes like a little more grown up and a
little more like earthy
i also see vivian vivian and mallory
like they have that same kind of sense
of humor where they're able to just like
dude they're both very
uh i
agree favorite part
that comes with character that you're
able to go to to talk about like the fun
things in the world
then vivian's hilarious outside of set
and onset
so i definitely see that ken
yeah
definitely who is most likely to
actually be the president of a club
nobody told me
malia or sophie
emily and sophie were my two picks too
as i say is like very responsible and i
think she would definitely be a
president of like the club i feel like
malia just has like leadership they both
are just very headstrong people that
take charge of something they care about
so i'm also very organized i agree very
girl boss party for now starting a club
at my school
okay we're talking about this later
who's most obsessed with the original
babysitter's club books malia
yeah
i think malia because i remember being
on one of her lives and she had this
like whole stack of like a bunch of
babysitters club books
like it was like a giant stack of them
oh yeah malia
don't look at me like that i feel like
i'm still on spot if you look at her
book collection it's like so
it's huge it has so many baby citrus
club books i'm kind of jealous it's
amazing who would make the best
babysitter in real life a seven way tie
honestly i feel like we're all what
sophie yeah julia
people malia they'd be good for malia
because i know sophie like she babysits
in real life she has like a whole bunch
of brothers right so i feel like she's
just yeah she's got the whole sitting
thing down it has a lot of younger
siblings so she has to deal with it all
the time he knows how to handle kids
really well and i mean on set with other
kids on set as well it was felt like we
were babysitting at times in the best
way possible we were able to have our
own kids have fun with them so that was
super awesome who's most likely to be
filming at tick tock on set me
yeah both of us
we were all filming think talks together
on set an a or vivian and nate vivian
romero shea yes
you guys wait i can't wait to post all
the tick tocks we've made but shay and i
would make these tick tocks in like
times three or times two speed and
they're like the funniest things ever
like so scary terrifying i was looking
back on my drafts and i was like oh i
could post this one when the show comes
out i have too many last i remember
being like oh um should we phone to talk
right now and everyone was like
oh
not again
who's most likely to burst into laughter
in the middle of a take
andra kendra
yes i
the way i knew the answer in my head
that's why i couldn't even get through
the question
and she has a very completely softer as
well so if she starts then you know the
rest of them yeah we all just lose it
you and i yeah
yeah
kendra
oh
i was about to say malia but i think
kendra would too
or you
no yeah definitely me i would i think i
have definitely pretty sure i have i
remember this one scene where we would
always laugh there was one scene where
mo was wearing a green shirt and she was
trying to teach me japanese and i said
the color green completely wrong
and we were doing like a group of scenes
and we could not stop laughing and there
have been instances where all of us are
bursting into laughter in the middle of
a take oh my gosh anytime you laugh on
set you like try so hard to compress it
and not laugh but it makes it worse and
it's like oh and you want to like try to
stay as professional as possible for the
other people around you but like all it
takes is for us to look at each other
and then like
explode into laughter so sometimes we
literally have to like avoid eye contact
pretend it's a game like the serious
face game we just have to plan
your actors we can sometimes keep a
straight face who texts most on the
group chat maybe
oh mo too a nay i think
not me
a nay
or you even
i was gonna say
or you
i know
yeah moe talks a lot in the group chat
yeah
yeah you do too though what can i say
the bsc group said it's like the one
group chat i actually respond
it's so fun who's most likely to be
caught taking a selfie if we're talking
about like nice selfies absolutely no
one but if we're talking about silly
ones that make us look then all of us
same then all of us for sure shay hey
yeah i was gonna say me or today
took a lot of photos oh my gosh i'm so
glad she took a lot of photos because it
wasn't crochet we would totally have
like no photos i actually really want to
say vivian she would steal my phone and
not only take selfies but also take
vlogs like fake vlogs on my phone just
randomly she'd be like hey shay can i
see your phone and i'm like sure and
then she just takes a bunch of photos so
tell me about my answer was literally
the same thing because like vivian will
take your phone and like you won't see
it for a while and then like you look
through your camera roll and it's just
like vivian's face and like she makes
these videos
oh my gosh they're so funny i feel like
shae she has a lot of like the cute
photos where like someone else takes the
photo for us and then i have like just a
bunch of ones where it's like a really
odd angle
i don't think any of us take selfies in
a serious manner it's always like making
weird faces or horrible angles it's not
even in a serious way like oh let me
take a good selfie for instagram it's
just like completely hilarious and it's
so fun it makes all of us smile so much
who gives the best advice
sophie
sophie does too shay and malia yeah yeah
yes you are malia you guys give really
good advice malia malia thanks all of us
but mostly okay yeah
just about any of the girls for advice
sophie she gives like me the best advice
ever queen queen of pep talks honestly
yeah
everyone on set is like what is mouth so
i just can't everyone can like be a
therapist honestly
honestly everyone though because like i
think anyone in the group i can reach
out to and they will literally just
absolutely i wholeheartedly agree but
malia you you tend to be the perfect
balance of logical and insane
[ __ ] up
thank you who is most likely to pull a
prank on everyone sophie
sophie
sorry something's like in my throat
you us
kendra oh kendra
i don't think anybody would pull a prank
that is like actually harmful but i
think just little funny pranks to like
make somebody laugh i think that'd
probably be kendra since we're
considered like the younger people we
just pull pranks on everyone and then
we're like always just like laughing for
no reason
these two were filming a scene down in
this creepy little cellar and it was
very emotional scene they were both
crying it was a whole thing it was a
very important moment for them but i had
to film this other scene where i'd wear
this completely insane outfit i decided
to scare them while the cameras were
running because film is forever and
that's the best thing
both of your weddings what a lovely
reminder
i came down those stairs in my very
scary outfit well they still think we're
filming the scene because the director
and i were in on it together then i
snuck in and i just stood there and
waited for them to turn around and see
me and when they did they both like
yelped
thank you sophie
cleanser for of course thanks buzzfeed
make sure to watch babysitter's club on
netflix october 11. bye bye thanks for
watching
[Music]
you